I'll do whatever is necessary to get the
best results from my client and
sometimes that means smiling and making
nice and sometimes it means being a
warrior and being very very tough with
the other side I often say I do live in
a war zone for women and believe me it's
a very ugly war zone and people who do
heart surgery they see a lot of blood
and often the person is being operated
on doesn't see as much blood as a
surgeon sees in the operating room well
what I do is a blood sport it has
serious consequences however so I'm
doing battle with some of the best and
the most highly paid attorneys in town
and often they'll play dirty it'll be
ugly it'll be vicious behind the scenes
and I'm ready for that I'm ready for
that battle and that's why they know
they have to take me seriously because
I'll do anything and everything that is
legal and peaceful to win for my clients
and I'm ready to fight back I'm not the
shy type if they're in my clients face i
consider that they're in my face and
they're going to have to go through me
and it's not going to be pretty if they
attack my client i'm going to stand up
for them i am going to be strong and
they're going to have to do what is
right and what is just and the only way
for them to make peace is going to be to
do justice with my clients my clients
know that and the opposing party knows
that so when the smoke all clears and
the shouting stops we're going to have
to have a just result and that and then
and only then are we going to be able to
shake hands on it at about a wind
all lawyers are governed by the Canon of
ethics of their particular state bar and
there are many lawyers including
high-profile lawyers who have crossed
the lines and done things which they
should not have done which they knew
they should not have done and they've
got in trouble and trap doors opened and
they've fallen right through they
disciplined by their state bars
sometimes they've been criminally
prosecuted and it's ended their careers
and it's really very very sad when that
happens I'm happy to say that we've been
practicing for 35 years never been
disciplined at all by the State Bar
we've been received many many
commendations from other lawyers for the
great work that we have done for our
clients we are very very careful to
always follow the ethical cannons which
govern us and we do so because we know
they're the right thing to do they are
the guidelines and they have to be
respected and we will not cross them for
anyone or anything or to achieve any
result but we can do what we can do and
we can do it well and win those hundreds
and millions of dollars for our clients
by acting in an ethical way there are a
lot of battles we can fight we know what
the weapons are that we need to fight
them and we use those weapons to the
fullest extent possible so unfortunately
some other lawyers don't exercise the
best judgments that they could exercise
they take unacceptable risks when they
cross those ethical boundaries and we
refuse to do so under any set of
circumstances